in the era we are we're in now i think
like we're past the golden age of
streaming
because we're past the point in time
where you could get
every show that you've physically
feasibly watched on one platform and
it's it's unfortunate that that's the
case
um but it's kind of evolved into like a
similar era to
what the cable era was like but i mean
when p
when corporations started to realize
that there was money in streaming this
was
this was going to be the way that things
were going to evolve unfortunately
because unfortunately money talks you
know and if there could be a platform
where
every anime you ever watch was on a
single platform i'm sure someone would
have done that already
you know i'm sure someone with a lot of
money would have done that already i
hate to be the bearer of bad news but
anime is a business
impossible to get into it unless you've
got like yeah massive investors
yeah like maybe maybe like 10 15 years
ago that's good
maybe you know if you at the start of
the streaming age like when crunchyroll
first started but like that time's past
now you can't just you can't just be
like the little guy
taking on the big guy anymore oh yeah i
was like quibby as well i had like what
like six billion dollars
the [ __ ] yeah exactly you don't even
know what quibby is [ __ ]
it's uh it was made it was founded by
the guy who uh
left disney and founded dreamworks uh
come from his name
um and made quibby a streaming service
and it was it was an absolute dumpster
but it had like billions of dollar in
investments like yeah but it disappeared
after like two weeks right or something
well it was like you got a free trial
then you had to pay
and like it literally just tanked like
immediately yeah yeah yeah like and but
they they
paid for so many original shows as well
they're just wait who's on there
i don't [ __ ] know i i didn't go on i
didn't i didn't yeah
i didn't even know about this oh yeah
yeah how did you know about this couple
of years ago i think was it a couple of
years ago that was like two years ago
yeah no it was like a year ago was it i
think it might i don't [ __ ] up
it's a recent map i don't even count
last year last year frankly just flew by
i
i can't i can't remember anything did
that be 2019 it was a year ago yeah
i'm still 22 as far as i'm concerned
2020 [ __ ] king crimson like existed
in 2020 and just like [ __ ] erased the
entire year and we just skipped it
literally felt like last month
was like april 2020. this is really
weird
yeah i mean we're already halfway
through 2021 which is terrifying didn't
mixer die as well
yeah mixer died yeah man [ __ ] i wish i
got offered to move to mixer
nice cash out yeah ninja's just like set
for life and
he's the only reason anyone knows about
mixer i think um
but like yeah i mean like even with
those failed platforms they had like
millions and billions of dollars
invested into them
by angel investors yeah they definitely
weren't started by [ __ ] kickstarters
yeah yeah
and unfortunately like even if you have
like
what's what what would be like the most
successful kickstarter of all time
what what i don't know what like you've
heard that's very telling that we can't
think of one
yeah i'm sure there is some good ones
out there i just i've never been
interested
yeah to get a pursuit any good
kickstarter you could just buy the thing
when it [ __ ] comes out yeah
yeah yeah and and because i'm just
thinking with the money that with the
money that
kickstarter can be people can invest
into kickstarter even like the most
successful kickstart of all time would
probably have trouble
getting into the streaming field the
only one i remember
was those like sunglasses that had the
built-in headphones into it
you remember those that was successful
there was a kickstarter i remember it
because it was like during my uni days
but there was this
there's this pair of sunglasses where on
the brim here it was like
this new technology and audio where it
would vibrate and the vibrations
would travel through your ears and the
music would come into your ears and i
remember it was a successful kickstarter
i was like
millions of dollars and but that's not
successful
yeah but is that the most successful
kickstarter of all time the oh yeah
oh yeah he's the most success are you
kidding me number eight
how much money did the uya raise uh
eight million five hundred ninety six
thousand
eight yeah right even if even if someone
raised
twenty million oh
even if somebody raised 200 300 million
dollars that doesn't mean [ __ ] for
streaming
you can't you can't buy much with that
no that's what that's what i'm trying to
say like even with the most successful
kickstarters of all time
to get into this field you need external
investors
if if they really want to challenge the
big guys you know because there's a
there's a lot of money in there right
broke yeah
you could gather all the anime fans in
the wall and it probably won't even be
enough don't understand if people can
invest in kickstarter after like it's
just track record it's just
poorly have you ever donated to a
kickstarter no why you saved like 20
dollars and you got to put 100 in for
some [ __ ] and it's like i'll just wait
till it comes
out i've done i've done a few but like
not like the stupid amount of money that
some people like
every time i look at a kickstarter and i
see like the you know the top tiers
which are like
a thousand ten thousand dollars and you
see like one left two left i'm like who
are these people because it's just
dropping ten thousand dollars
for stuff that genuinely needs the money
i would be more inclined like a game or
something that i like i'm into i would
but
i haven't though but yeah most of the
time the stuff that gets the most is
just like [ __ ] pre-orders essentially
you're just
the products made they know what they're
doing and you're just pre-ordering yeah
i mean with kickstarter i feel like if
it's a small indie project or something
that you can see
feasibly getting funded on kickstarter
yeah i would support it i mean i
i think the last kick starter i
supported was actually uh the
trigger anime i think they funded
the second ova of like little witch
academy yeah yeah yeah i supported that
yeah
that makes sense to me that seems like a
like this is why kickstarter should
exist
yeah yeah but like if you're if you're
coming in trying to change like
stir up an entire industry or whatever
kickstarter is just not going to do it
anymore i think kickstarter is really
good for
you know a small indie team to do some
kind of project but
on like a [ __ ] industry changing
project you need something else
usually kickstarters is for like you
know like kind of it stops at an
artistic level right
it's not really the thing that you go
into to be like
i'm gonna cause a scene in the in the
industry you know the [ __ ] everything
on kickstarter is the same [ __ ] it's
like all right
get the stock image of people running
play the play the music mood and the the
the you know the you know the the
ukulele yeah that one or like there's
always
there's always some like motivational
thing and then it's just like have you
ever had this problem that isn't a
problem
well now we can solve it and then it
looks amazing and then you think about
it like it's all [ __ ]
it's always it's always the same type of
people that are kickstarter too isn't it
yeah it's always like the way to overly
enthusiastic like
my name is kyle it'll either be someone
from california or someone from eastern
europe
yeah like with a really thick accent
explaining why
his fridge is the best fridge and it's
like okay
that's cool that's fine i just don't
want it with our last project the
walking fridge
we raised two hundred thousand dollars
that's insane i just i just realized
that kickstarters are basically the
modern infomercials
yeah yeah pretty much i just don't
believe
any any any single advertisement
where someone gives it to a random
person
and they're like whoa it's amazing i
just don't believe that i if even if it
actually happens
i just don't want i don't i don't even
believe it when there's another thing
which says like not a paid actor yeah
you sure about that
oh you did you said go back to anime
tube did you see the [ __ ]
testimonials they had
i think they just got like some random
people they found on discord to give
them testimonials of that app or
something
like that it's good what was the
testimonial
let me let me let me see let me see let
me see if i can bring it up right now
but uh yeah i mean it's it's it's all
it's all the same right it's
literally yeah it's just like you know
i frankly don't really do i don't trust
anyone who shows me their reviews let me
see your reviews i'll have a look it is
routinely maintained it's comfortable
it's quite
logical and ergonomic it's way beyond
any competition
i like it of course it's beyond the
[ __ ] competition when you can just
take the licenses
like rip them off a dvd the best app for
on hand anime i used to spend days
looking up series
but now i just use this app with ease
thank you robert
thank you stefan roberts and james
with the most rudimentary anime profile
pictures i've ever seen yeah i mean it's
it's just
it's like we're going to look back on
this and it's just going to feel like a
fever dream
you know i yeah whatever it it already
does
it's [ __ ] stupid don't do that